Alex Cerf word of Edward Jones is with
parties all right Alex a financial
advisor for ED Jones Edward Jones and
also chess stylist I mean take a look at
these socks in the shoes the socks are
really kicking it though got a bishop
but what's that position on the sock
I'll give questions yeah I don't know
the position is I think you have some
cufflinks to that you're styling
fully-equipped today Maurice man he was
ready to come on this show today that's
before the grand master of fashion here
with you and Jennifer so you do it bro
appreciate you and I'm also looking at
this list and I do you you know
financial advisor Fred Jones of 7 is it
7 million 7 trillion or how much under
some big numbers 7 million clients a
trillion dollars in assets and under
management worldwide so when you asked
her needs help with his billions of
dollars he goes to guys like you of
course but I've seen other titles chess
campus young professional boards VP
corporate Chesley chess campus
ambassador average chess player clearly
one of those hidden pictures in the
chest community here tell us about your
role in the chess campus and on the
young professionals board yeah well
thanks Maurice and thanks for this
opportunity to come and share I'm very
excited about some of the things that we
are doing with the young professionals
board I've had the opportunity to serve
as the vice president for two years now
and one of our biggest goals is to bring
awareness to this great facility we
believe that we are the epicenter of
chess and the chess world here in st.
Louis and so being a part of bringing
that to st. Louis has been really good
so very excited to be a part of that and
yeah some pictures there of the
corporate chess league as well so those
are some good food
oh yeah it's a it's big-time go all-out
for sure and tell me you know before we
got on the air I mentioned that we had a
corporate wrestling in New York as well
and you said yeah they got it from us
the little rivalry there are you guys
gonna expand and maybe start competing
against other cities as well
I would love to have that be a part of
the vision initially it came up as a
colleague of mine and I were talking
just about our enjoyment of chess and
this kind of idea developed organically
about how corporations you know maybe
have like a softball league and they
play one another in that city and we
just kind of thought well why not be
able to have a chess league and so I was
able to present that to the the club
here and just kind of ran with it it was
a great opportunity to network be
engaged have some companies come
together and I know you're from Brooklyn
and so yes absolutely we would love to
see a New York City STL Championship
someday of some corporations so that
would be great be careful what you ask
New York of course you're serious in st.
Louis here as well and you serious about
giving Edward Jones as of course given
to the Chess Club philanthropic Li tell
us about their contribution to what is
the magic of chess in st. Louis yeah
it's great to be a part of a firm that I
would describe as really a pillar in the
community when it comes to philanthropy
I think that over the years since 1922
when the firm was established by Ted
Jones jr. and his dad that it's just
been a part of the culture for
volunteerism as well as giving back and
that philanthropic reach has now
extended to the the chess community in
the chess world which makes me really
happy because first of all these things
I do it's it's from a fan base and then
being able to get engaged and to see the
the value that that Edward Jones places
on some of the the things that we're
doing here at the Chess Club and the
world chess Hall of Fame is is a whole
lot of fun from that perspective to be
able to yeah just see them recognize
that as well and so for us as a firm to
be involved in what the community is
doing here at the the Chess Hall of Fame
and the the Chess Club has been really
exciting it's important to have fans
like yourselves or in corporations those
of you out there who do work for
corporate America
definitely start pushing your CEOs
support chess it makes a difference
you're a big chess fan
you must been following the amazing
games that are going on here you have
the benefit of having five rounds behind
you who do you think is going to win the
tournament
well I'll mention first of all I feel
like we're just completely spoiled here
in st. Louis with all the top-tier
talent that we have that comes through
with tournament after tournament of
seeing the best in the world and just
the the vision of dr. Jeanne and and Rex
to bring this type of a tournament which
I think is so important to inspire young
girls inspire young women to be a part
of chess I brought my daughter here on
the weekend and so her and I went
upstairs got to see some of the players
going and so to that effect I think that
Alexandra of course has had a great
first half of the tournament I think
that well good Nina has really just
played some inspired chess I think that
the game I think it was the fourth round
just kind of channeling towel it seemed
like the fifth round fifth round the
creative attacking that she I was at me
it was like actually exciting just like
the sacrifices she's making things like
that but if I had to make a prediction
prediction I would certainly go with the
American and go with Irina crush I hope
that she pulls through I know only about
a half point behind today and the game
today could play a big part in that so
hope to see her pull it out you know you
and only one other commentator picked
arena Christ Oh pick the home girl pick
the US player you know it's kind of sad
but at least great minds think alike
all right see now the last thing before
you go when are you gonna have another
one of those great chess parties because
you guys have it yes after dark that was
fun man of the music the the first of
all the deejay was off the chain yeah
he's off he was incredible the guy was
was not only in a turntable he was
taking up various instruments and
playing them while the music was going
on I was very impressed by him and then
all the color
everything that was so much glowy globe
stuff around the net I never seen
grandmasters wear so glow sticks and
glow necklaces you guys got something
planned but you know even grandmasters
have to come and cut loose every now and
again and enjoy just some fun times I
don't need any excuse to cut loose so I
think be on the lookout I guess I'll say
that we we have some things in the works
and I think that we'll be seeing some
things here pretty soon with some
opportunities again fantastic well Alex
curve for a great fan of the game
superfan we need folks like you to
support us and of course Edward Jones
keep up the great work thank you very
much appreciate it